It's hardcore history.
I've been podcasting since like the
Stone Age,
2005 and way back then and for a long
time afterwards I kind of considered all
the other people who were podcasting as
my colleagues were not really in the
sort of industry where you,
so yes,
my colleagues and we published papers or
whatever the normal idea of of what you
might consider a colleague to be,
but it really felt the same.
Right.
You're struggling through the same
things,
learning the same thing as running into
each other in places either in person or
digitally these days.
Of course it's a lot harder to call
every podcast or your colleague when I
think I saw a number recently that it's
north of 500,000
podcast or something,
but the person I'm about to talk to is
undoubtedly my podcast colleague
because,
well heck,
he's a history podcast or so right
there.
We're in a pretty pretty small gene pool
and he is one of the great podcasters
ever is the history of Rome.
PODCAST is legendary in my mind.
It sort of makes him the audio,
the modern audio equivalent of Edward
Gibbon,
where he,
he goes into like the length and breadth
of the entire Roman experience to the
fall of the western empire.
It's hugely popular and one of those
podcasts that should be in some section
of the hall of fame someday.
His other one is an amazingly ambitious
project,
which he pulls off wonderfully.
And judging from the success,
uh,
everyone seems to like revolutions where
he looks at different revolutions.
So it'll be very interesting to talk to
Mike Duncan today about his new book,
the storm before the storm.
And if you don't know enough about this,
his book will educate you wonderfully.
He show,
of course is available out there.
We did a,
the longest series we ever did was on
this period of Roman history in death
throes of the republic.
So there's lots of stuff out there,
but I have a feeling most of you are
already going to know a ton of this
stuff because Rome is wildly popular,
which is one of the first questions I
ask my history,
podcast colleague,
the Great Mike Duncan.
Once upon a time I wanted to do a
podcast on Cleopatra and I sat down,
decided it,
ordered a bunch of books,
and then tried to figure out where you
should start the story of Cleopatra and
every time I would go backwards I would
find a domino connected to another
domino.
And another domino long story short that
show I wanted to do Cleopatra about,
or the show I wanted to do about
Cleopatra turned into the longest series
we've ever done because you have to go
all the way back to,
uh,
a long way in Roman history for the
dynamics to become,
you know,
even remotely clear and people tend to
focus on,
you know,
if this is the titanic story,
the actual sinking of the ship.
But Mike,
your new book,
the storm before the storm is about the
iceberg and the striking of the iceberg,
you know,
tell us a little bit about,
this story that most people don't know
as well as the actual sinking of the
ship.
Yeah.
The way that I put it in my book is the
storm before the storm,
the beginning of the end of the Roman
republic,
and it covers the period from 1:46
BC around there to about 78 BC,
which is the death of Sala and it covers
the couple of generations before Julius
Caesar comes along,
before Octavian comes along,
before Antony and Cleopatra are around,
um,
to start looking as you say it,
the things that led up to the collapse
of the Roman republic rather than just
jumping right into it and you say it's,
you know,
people like to focus on the sinking of
the ship.
And I say,
uh,
that,
that jumping into Cesar is like jumping
into a movie,
uh,
at,
at the third act,
at the beginning of the third act where
you,
you know,
everything is,
loud and crazy and people are fighting
with each other.
And obviously people are really
passionately committed to this,
that,
or the other thing.
But you don't know how it got to this
point.
You don't know what,
what were the,
what were the problems that led the
republic to be so brittle that it could
be blown apart a couple of generations
later and that's what I hope that the
book is able to explore and then when
you read it and you have completed with
it,
then you'll have a much richer
understanding of why we,
why what happens with Caesar happens.
Let's talk about why we even care what
happens to Caesar.
I'm a little amazed at the not just
modern but ongoing public interest and
remember a public that is generally not
thought to be all that history,
knowledgeable or even cared that much
about it and yet we can continually
publish books and make movies and and
have discussions that,
that draw comparisons to this republic
for more than 2000 years ago.
What do you think accounts for the
enduring interest on the part of even
lay people to this place where if you
think about it,
no one should even be.
They shouldn't be in the front of
anyone's mind.
Fifteen hundred,
2000 years ago.
It's a.
it's a good question.
I mean,
like,
for,
for people like us,
you know,
it's just,
it's so inherently interesting that it's
almost weird to step back and say like,
why would anybody be interested in Rome
because Rome is,
at least to me.
So inherently interesting.
Um,
I think what it gets to is that people
have,
people know that Rome was this ancient,
powerful civilization and it almost is
the epitome of what a imperial power is,
what civilizational power is.
We know that it lasted for a thousand
years or more if you include the
byzantines.
So I think it's,
I think Rome is always going to have a
place in the collective imagination as
you go.
Okay.
What if you're at all interested in
history at all?
Let's go to sort of the big and
important parts of history and um,
you're always going to then wind up in
Rome and specifically where people are
going to wind up is that,
is that era between,
let's say the arrival of Julius Caesar
and like the death of Nero ran at the
death of the Julio Cottey and dynasty,
that particular era of Roman history in
part because it's so well documented and
we know so much about it,
uh,
is always going to be the place where
people go a to.
If they become interested in Rome,
that's where they're going to wind up.
And it's a lot the same way that I think
that no matter what,
like the Napoleonic age is going to be
permanently something that people keep
going back to and back to even 2000
years later.
And you're like,
wow,
this is just like some obscure,
you know,
kind of temporary French empire.
There is,
there is something about the force of
the personalities and the force of the,
the political power that is being
expressed.
That's always going to draw people's
attention.
You know,
I,
I see that with Napoleon just like I see
that with a Hitler or,
or even the Genghis Khan,
but,
but to me the difference is the length
of it instead of one supreme figure that
that is searing across the pages of the
history book and there are innately
interesting.
You have numerous figures.
I mean,
just going through your book,
it's one fascinating individual that
seems to be almost.
Well,
I mean,
when you think about what the quota of
great men should be in any given
civilization during any given time,
the period disgusting.
Your book seems to be an era where
humanity in that place,
in that time is exceeding its normal
quota of fascinating August human
beings.
I would say.
So.
And it's always been a bit surprising to
me.
Uh,
you know,
having gone through the history of Rome
and you know,
gone through the entire history of Rome
and pretty minute detail,
um,
that,
that particular period between the Pi
and then Maurice and Sala was always,
um,
who was always a period that I wanted to
come back to.
Like I,
I kinda had to put a pin in it very
early on and was like,
you know,
this is,
this is an era that's gonna be a lot.
It's going to be worth coming back to
and to have nobody really have written
the book that I wrote,
which is let's just focus on this 50 or
60 year period all on its own.
I won't make this the first couple of
chapters and a larger book about the
fall of the republic.
I won't make it one chapter in a larger
history about,
you know,
just Roman civilization.
But to really like hone in on this
particular period.
You know,
I would,
I,
I'd always kind of,
I would watch the lists with one I like
if somebody going to finally discover
that this is a great untapped wealth of
material,
um,
and nobody,
nobody quite put it together.
So I was able to step in and,
and now I hope deliver a book that will
explain why.
I think when people end the book,
they're going to be like,
why hasn't this been covered in more
detail?
I think that'll be one of the big
questions coming out of it for people.
Yeah.
I love your subtitle,
the beginning of the end of the Roman
republic.
It sounds Churchill,
Ian,
but you maybe you could have called it
also,
um,
you know,
the era when things broke because that
way that really is kind of what it was,
you know,
and you can see like you were talking
about in the book,
they,
the Romans didn't have this written
constitution.
They had sort of a set of conduct rules
that were just innately understood by
everyone in customs.
And when they broke that,
it's like,
okay,
there is no written constitution.
So once someone violates the way we do
things right,
the way of the elders,
uh,
all bets are off,
right?
It seemed that way.
Um,
were there,
there was,
there was this thing like when Rome
triumphs and,
and what happens in 1:46
BC for people that aren't,
like,
caught up with this is that Rome
conquered carthage for the last time.
Their great rival.
I mean Hannibal during the second punic
war,
that's about 50 years or so in the past.
Um,
but they're,
they're great rivalry with carthage is
now over and Rome has emerged
victorious.
They also decide to just outright
conquer and annex grease into the Roman
state.
So at this point in 1:46
BC,
Rome is without question the strongest
power in the Mediterranean world and
nobody's going to be able to challenge
them.
There is something about this trial
actually opens up a whole host of new
problems for the Republican,
for the leadership of the product that
they just sort of start to fail to
address and fail to deal with.
And it creates a powerfully new,
like confrontational style of domestic
politics that had never really existed
before.
The Roman Senate and the Roman elites
had always been pretty clubby with each
other.
They had always been like,
oh,
there are some,
you know,
will ultimately make compromises with
each other.
Or you know,
if we don't all agree on something,
we'll just,
we'll just put it to bed.
And what happens after 1:46
is you start having these leaders start
to break away and start to tap into new
energies that are floating around out
there.
And with this new confrontational style
of Roman politics,
yeah,
people start abandoning those old
unwritten norms and unspoken a modes of
behavior.
And once you start down that road,
I mean tell you can,
you can pull out of it what,
what happened to the Romans is that they
were not able to pull out of it.
And if you start going down this road,
you ultimately discovered that even
written laws,
even following written laws,
is merely accustomed.
It's merely a norm.
Um,
there's no,
there's nothing about a piece of paper
with laws written on it that compels me
to do anything to follow that law.
I'm just simply,
I'm giving it power with my own because
that's how we do things.
But if somebody say as a,
you know,
an army or a gun or a baseball bat,
that actually is the ultimate definer of
power.
It's just brute force.
So once you start giving up on sort of
what you would call,
oh,
minor unspoken rules,
you eventually will get to the point
where everybody has to admit that only
brute force is really what's at play.
You know,
I love that line,
whether it was really sad or not that,
you know,
history doesn't repeat,
but it sometimes rhymes and I look at
the Roman republic,
I think like everyone does and you know,
it's hard not to see,
um,
patterns and,
and similar dynamics and I think if for
no other reason than because it's
another commercial republic that's large
and imperial and right there you're
going to have some things that look
similar and we all understand that if
you look a little beneath the surface,
there's a ton of things that are
different.
I mean slavery outright,
slavery for example.
But you point out in your book,
and I thought it was interesting you
were,
you were drawn comparisons to if the US
and the Roman republic are following a
similar charted course,
for lack of a better word,
where would we be now in terms of where
the Romans were?
Can you talk a little about that?
Because I thought that was.
I mean,
if you look at the punic wars is like
the world wars and whatnot,
I think it's a fascinating way to come
up to a conclusion saying,
okay,
we've done this,
we haven't done this yet.
So where do you put us in the book
compared to,
um,
Roman history in a similar place.
Right?
So all,
all caveats aside that this isn't,
this is not actually the way that
history works.
We're not like in some.
That's right.
We're speculating wildly and it responds
to absolutely.
Right.
So that's what I do.
Mike,
Welcome to my show.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
So let's say that the Roman Empire is
out there and there was like a thousand
years worth of history and we're sitting
here in the United States or in the
West.
Generally at the beginning of the 21st
century.
You want to say like,
w,
w what,
what is there that we can look to in
Roman history is,
is there a period in time that we can
look to that is more analogous to our
own situation than another and it,
it's really,
it's a lot by process of elimination,
uh,
where,
you know,
are we a brand new little city state
that has just recently been colonized or
founded by,
you know,
a group of a dissident and vagabonds and
escaped slaves,
like know that,
that happened 400 years ago in our own
history.
That would be,
you know,
the early days of the colonization of
North America.
Uh,
are we at a stage where a group of
disgruntled aristocrats overthrows the
king and establishes a new king list
republic that is more or less an elite
lead oligarchy.
Like,
no,
that would be,
if anything,
that's,
you know,
that's the founding fathers,
that's the American revolution.
Um,
then what Rome does is,
is it emerges as,
as a new republic and over the next
couple of hundred years,
it starts to expand slowly across Italy
in a series of a series of wars.
There collectively dub the Sam night
wars that wind up with Rome being the
most dominant power in the Italian
peninsula on the Italian peninsula.
So it was the United States a recently
emerged regional power.
Um,
I,
again,
I don't think that anybody would
describe the United States as a recently
emerged regional power and all of that
probably corresponds to,
you know,
our slow and steady conquest of North
America and everything that we did to
the American Indians,
uh,
battling with Mexico and taking their,
the entire north half of their country.
And then you even get later on and you
say,
well,
after that Rome goes to war with
Carthage,
goes to war with Greece,
goes to war in Spain,
and they emerge as this dominant,
what you might call a global power,
at least in the context of the
Mediterranean.
And again,
the United States isn't even there
because we did all of that.
Uh,
we are one of the acknowledged great
powers.
And especially after the Cold War in the
19 nineties,
you were describing the United States as
a hyper power almost.
And I think that's been tempered quite a
bit in the last few years,
but certainly we're not finding our
footing for the first time as a global
power.
We've been dealing with those issues.
Um,
you know,
since the end of world war two and all
through the Cold War.
So then you push forward a little bit
more and you say,
okay,
well has the republic,
you know,
have we collapsed into a,
a generations long civil war war,
a war Lord has in effect a emerged
victorious from and set himself up as a
dictator.
No,
that hasn't happened yet.
So if we haven't gotten to that point
yet,
if the republic has not yet collapsed,
and I certainly don't believe that the
republic has collapsed.
Um,
then you say,
okay,
well maybe the United States is kind of
now roughly in this same setting where
after Rome had emerged as a global
power,
but before the republic collapsed,
let's,
let's take a look at this era.
It's the beginning of the end of the
republic,
which is right after this period,
1:46
BC,
which as we said earlier in the show
earlier in this interview was because
already a period that is inherently
fascinating in its own right.
And as it turns out,
I think that they were dealing with a
number of issues that you could say the
United States is dealing with right now.
And so it's worth going through what the
Romans went through and how they
responded to it.
And maybe it could,
um,
maybe it could influence how we decide
to deal with our own problems.
Today.
I was playing a silly game while I was
reading your book is to remind me of a
bunch of things that I haven't,
I haven't looked at in a while and,
and the battles over public land and the
distribution of land to veterans and all
that stuff in the problem that the
Romans were having,
keeping armies in the field when they
were essentially,
you know,
conscripts is not really the right word,
but farmer armies that had to go home
and tend to their home.
We're now on long service,
a thousand miles away from home and the
farm's going to hack and how long can
you maintain?
And I thought,
you know,
if we tried to run our current foreign
policy in the United States with a
military that was operating with the
draft situation that we had,
say in the 19 fifties,
I don't know if we could do it,
how much does the dynamic of having,
um,
you know,
a bunch of veterans coming home from
these wars and having,
you know,
real gripes about the situation that
they find themselves in the fact that
they might have to go back in service.
The fact that their homes are falling
apart while they're gone.
Talk to talk a little about that dynamic
check.
Reminds me a little the fry core in
Germany or the bonus marchers in our own
history.
I mean,
a bunch of long service military
veterans angry with nothing to do.
Sounds like a recipe for,
um,
political change.
Yeah,
I would,
I would say so.
And what what is happening is it's one
of these situations where,
again,
the Romans or had been more or less
running,
what you might call a glorified militia
were you were,
you were,
you would enter into the service,
you would actually,
if,
yeah,
if harvest time came and everybody was
still fighting each other,
like both sides would quit the field and
everybody would go home and harvest
their fields.
And these imperial wars of expansion
that Rome got caught in a yes,
starts to take the poor,
the lower class citizens away from their
farms,
away from their families for longer and
longer periods of time.
And so this period of triumph is for
the,
for the Roman state,
for the republic itself as an entity.
The Senate and the people of Rome,
um,
turns out to be fairly economically
disastrous for a lot of these lower
class a Roman citizens.
They're going to start to lose their
farms.
They're going to start to get bought out
by wealthy neighbors because you take,
you know,
you'd rather take some money and get out
while you can then watch it all go to
ruin.
So yeah,
it really does.
And the,
and the bonus,
the bonus marchers are a good example of
this,
um,
which happened right before,
you know,
right,
right in the midst of the Great
Depression here in the United States is
that they,
they had these grievances,
they had these legitimate grievances,
their families had had these farms for
in perpetuity,
you know,
going back into the misty eras of the
early republic or even the kingdom days
and they've,
they're now starting to lose all of that
and their traditional ways of life are
being upset and they are feeling that
the Senate and the government of Rome is
a,
they are consolidating all of this
massive imperial wealth.
But none of it seems to be trickling
down to the poor farmers,
to the poorer citizens.
So you have a,
you have a situation where these new
leaders,
as I was saying,
you can,
you can start to break out and say,
hey,
I as a,
as a noble leader,
you can say,
Hey,
I think that there's an opportunity for
me here to,
uh,
get enormous political influence and
political power and political popularity
by promising these people who have all
these grievances.
I'm going to,
I'm going to solve your problems.
We're going to go to the rich.
We're going to take their land by
basically by force.
We're going to chop it up and we're
going to redistribute it to all of you.
This is an incredibly popular thing that
can be done.
And this opens the new,
like pop goolarri style of Roman
politics,
which is instead of this elite noble
consensus being the driver of your
policies,
it's directly appealing to the rural
peasants in the urban plebs who are
feeling negative effects from Rome's
imperial tramp rather than a bunch of
positive effects.
Well,
and it brings up the age old question.
I'd like to get your opinion on it.
As a guy who's talked about roam as much
or more than anyone,
I can think of the idea that,
that these people who appealed to the
popular crowd or were they really,
was that,
was that a real position or was that,
you know,
they just had latched onto a political,
uh,
when they put their finger in the wind,
find out,
oh,
this cause of giving land to the
veterans is popular.
So I'll do that.
It seems to me that,
that if I look at it as a,
as a novice,
some of these reformers look more real
than others.
Um,
do you have a feeling?
I mean like,
uh,
a ks and Tiberias groggy.
I mean,
to me those seem people always like to
compare them to the Kennedy brothers
that that's ridiculous.
But at the same time you have two
brothers both assassinated,
uh,
both that a lot of people were able to
romantically put a lot of hopes in and,
and lionize afterwards.
I mean,
do you look at those guys as,
um,
as sincere reformers or are they all
charlatans work in a political angle?
Um,
well,
or are none of them?
No,
I had no,
I,
I have an answer to this because now
I've,
now I've gone through it and this is,
as you point out,
this is one of the great debates in
Roman history generally,
and also just like world history in
general is,
you know,
are these various popular reformers,
are they merely cynical demagogues or
are they genuinely interested in
reforming the state?
Um,
and certainly even while they were still
alive,
their,
their um,
their allies were saying,
oh,
they're,
you know,
they're driven by lofty ideals and a,
and a genuine regard for the people and
their enemies are producing pamphlet to
the say,
oh no,
they're,
they're trying to make themselves the
new kings of Rome.
So we're,
I,
I do come down on it about the Grok.
I in particular that I think that they
were interested in genuine reform.
There was no like,
altruism at work here.
I mean,
we're talking about like,
hi Roman politics.
There's not a lot of altruism going
around out there,
but I think that they saw simultaneously
that a path to personal power,
which is what they were after,
they were incredibly ambitious,
uh,
could simultaneously solve a lot of the
problems that Rome was now dealing with
as it transitioned from being merely an
Italian city state.
One,
one among many to like the rulers of the
entire Mediterranean world.
Um,
but they existed on a spectrum where the
same,
you know,
the same meal,
you have popolare energy coming out of
the rural peasants or the urban plebs,
uh,
even the lower equestrian classes that
have a lot of wealth but don't have a
lot of,
um,
input politically,
uh,
those can be harnessed by people like
the Grok I.
and they can also be harnessed by
cynical demagogues who,
yes,
are just there to say,
you're angry.
I know that you're angry.
I'm going to help you channel that anger
and I'm going to tell you who's to blame
for all of your problems.
And,
and then I'm going to point you at the
people who I'm telling you are to blame
for it.
And a,
Oh,
wouldn't you know it,
the people who are to blame for it are
my personal enemies,
so you can use that same sort of,
it becomes a,
it becomes quite a revolutionary energy.
Um,
you can start to use that and manipulate
it.
So I think it's never fair to say that
all of them are sincere reformers and,
or all of them are cynical demagogues.
It's,
it's quite a mix of the two and people
are going to land on a spectrum and
people say,
you know,
people bring up the Kennedy Brothers for
the Rock Guy,
which doesn't really hold a lot of
water.
Um,
but if there is anybody in American
history who does look like the Rock,
I think it's the roosevelts,
um,
where,
what theater Roosevelt and Franklin
Roosevelt and that the progressive
reforms that they were making,
both of them were incredibly ambitious.
Both of them wanted to be president.
Both of them kind of wanted to be
president forever.
Um,
and they were called traitors to their
class.
Yeah.
And they were,
of course they were the.
Absolutely.
And so they're very similar to the GROK
I in that way that they were,
you know,
inner inner,
inner circle,
nobility and uh,
they're using all of their power and
wealth and influence to really disrupt
what the elites have going for them.
So I think if anybody is out there in
American history that does look like the
guy,
it's probably the Roosevelt.
Well,
I'm enjoying the analogy comparison too
much to stop now.
So maybe you can give me,
have you ever thought about some of
these other figures in your book and
thought about American examples?
I mean,
I can look at like a huey long,
for example,
and see someone that maybe would have
fit back into the Roman things.
I remember.
Was it Manchester?
Manchester's book on Macarthur and
American Caesar.
I mean,
there's always comparisons.
Um,
you know,
when you look at the Solos in the
maurices and Cato,
the elder and all those folks,
do you have any analogies that you often
think of when you think of some of these
major figures?
Well,
not to,
you know,
not to rain on anybody's parade,
but once you get,
once you get onto that like granular
level,
like,
like who is,
you know,
who would this be?
Um,
it does start to get harder to pin
people down.
Like was macarthur was Macarthur and
American Caesar.
Uh,
I don't know,
but it seems like probably a good thing
that truman fired him.
I think it's an insult to Caesar myself,
but I'm biased.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
I would say so.
I mean like,
yeah,
I have of all the people that I've ever
gone through that you can compare to
Julius Caesar.
I mean like it's Napoleon.
That's exactly.
Yeah.
Nobody else really like measures up to
that particular class of,
you know,
having the totality of like I'm,
I can be genocidal and also like reform
the metric system and I'm a genius.
Yes.
So if I successfully dodged the
question.
Yes,
I think so.
Well done.
Um,
so,
so okay.
So then let's talk then a little bit
about the dynamics here because you
know,
it's funny because when look at the
Roman system,
it seems to be the wonderful,
unless you want to go to the Greeks,
but it's the wonderful example of,
of the class divisions and then the
problems inherent with,
with class warfare and sharing of power.
I mean if you want it to describe,
I mean we're talking about the iceberg
that sinks the titanic here and we can
talk about rules shifting and warlords
and everything,
but,
but what was it that shifted in terms of
a public being willing to accept
senatorial control by a,
as you pointed out in the book,
a really small number of people in a
fundamental sense and,
and,
and be able to push.
I mean the,
the,
the tribune of the plebs was one
systemic tool that was introduced to
help balance out those powers.
Could you say that that whole era
between Tiberius Caracas and maybe
Caesar is an example of class warfare
sort of playing out.
I mean,
how much of a role would you give to
that ambitious men versus class warfare
versus cycles and trends?
It's
really difficult to get into because
Roman politics did operate differently
than modern western politics.
Like the client system.
Yeah.
So the,
the first and most important thing is to
say that these are,
these are more like clan rivalries than,
um,
than class warfare where,
you know,
you're a,
you're a patron,
you're a leader and you have this
network of clients who are all attached
to you.
And then your political rivals have that
same network of,
um,
of clients who were all attached to
them.
So this is really like,
this is really clans running into each
other with,
with almost like nobles and retainers.
If you wanted to use like a medieval
analogy rather than,
rather than like,
oh,
we're,
you know,
we're the lower classes and we are
trying to overthrow you guys the upper
classes.
But that said,
um,
during this era,
right after,
after 1:46,
I think you do have a new class style of
politics that one of these rival clans
can take advantage of.
Right?
And so hopefully I'm able to paint this
correctly.
So what it is,
is you have this ability to go out into
just the voting public,
right?
Because all of these people could vote,
um,
the rural peasants,
the urban pubs,
they could all vote and you could use
the popular assemblies to pass
legislation to make yourself and your
own clan very,
very popular.
So this is almost something that like
you would be sitting around with your
senatorial family.
You're,
you're an ambitious senatorial family,
and you're like,
how are we going to get power,
um,
of that appeal to the populace is an
available method of doing it.
So you're ginning up class interests and
you're pointing them at often.
Usually you're pointing it at the
corrupt Senate and saying like,
we're gonna,
you know,
we are going to deliver to you what the
corrupt Senate has been denying you.
But five years later or 10 years later,
maybe your rival has decided to,
to try to adopt one of these popular
platforms and use that.
Well now you suddenly become the
defender of old senatorial interests
because your rival was the one who is
now doing the popular program and so it
was,
it was a lot of like taking on and
putting off of hats where you were
temporary,
you might temporarily be the leader of a
popular movement and then 10 years later
you might be standing in lock step with
the Senate.
So it was very,
it was,
it was a lot more fluid I think than,
um,
than anything that would be going on,
say,
like,
you know,
with,
with battles between unions,
battles between like socialist and
capitalists in the modern era where
there's really class interests involved.
And you really had also like lower class
leaders doing the leading in that sense,
which you don't really get that in Roman
history.
No.
And it was interesting because,
uh,
you had included in the book something,
I think it was cato,
the elder had talked about,
and we're getting back here to,
to the changes in Rome because of the
punic wars on the various conquest about
the amount of wealth that was being
dragged back to Rome by some of these
people,
you know,
because most of the people don't benefit
from these conquests,
but some of these commanders and whatnot
would come back.
You were talking about 40,000
pounds of silver and things like that.
Talk a little about how,
and this is,
this is such a Roman moralizer point of
view,
right?
About how the nouveau riche Romans or
forgetting their values,
but you included it in the book.
How much did the,
did the Roman system change?
Because all of a sudden it went from a,
well,
at least the,
the portrayals of it make it sound like
more spartan,
more old values to cato,
the elder looking at the nice figs and
saying,
Carthage must be destroyed.
I,
I think that the role of this new wealth
there,
there's a couple of things that all of
this new wealth does,
um,
does bring into play,
right?
Like the Cato,
the elder style critique,
which is that all of this wealth
degraded the morality of the upper class
or degraded the morality of the Romans,
I think is less important.
I don't think that that is,
is a huge driver of,
of,
of what the problem was.
I don't think it was that the wealth
degraded their morals.
How do you think it was that it created
a skyrocketing economic inequality,
right?
Where there had always been rich and
poor in Rome,
right?
That,
that is going to be true.
Going all the way back.
What was happening is that as,
as you just mentioned,
and I read about this in the book,
that you have these legions going out
there going out to Greece,
Macedonia,
they're going to north Africa and
they're bringing back 300,000
gold coins.
They're bringing back 80,000
pounds of raw silver.
I mean,
literally like the Specie of the
available specie of the Mediterranean is
being thrown into Roman wagons and
hauled back to Rome,
all of which is being controlled mostly
by that upper class senatorial elite or
the,
you know,
the richer equestrian classes,
right?
The sort of the subset of the people who
are one step below the senators.
These guys are the ones who are
controlling all of this wealth.
And I do think that far from degrading
the morality of the thing,
it does degrade the socioeconomic
system.
Where,
what are they going to do with all this
gold?
Uh,
the Romans did not.
They did not sit around counting,
counting their gold pieces like scrooge,
uh,
in,
you know,
in a Christmas carol.
They want to invest their gold into
things and most especially they want to
invest it in land.
So their,
their ability to now command this huge,
huge amount of wealth they're pouring it
into trying to buy up as much land as
they possibly can.
And this does lead to the further
dispossession of all of those poor Roman
farmers,
uh,
that we talked about a couple of minutes
ago,
so that there's that process that is an
unfolding,
that wealth being controlled by a few
rich families is leading those rich
families to expand their own land
holdings across Italy.
And that's just gonna disrupt the entire
socioeconomic system at that had been in
existence for hundreds of years.
And that's just the one thing that
they're investing all their money in.
And the other thing that they're
investing all of their money in his
slaves so they're now able to,
the richer Romans are now able to bring
slaves into the system on,
again,
an unprecedented scale.
Uh,
the Romans had always had slaves.
Slaves had always been around.
But now you really have the slaves
beginning to do most of the,
at least commercial labor of this,
of Roman society.
They're out there.
They're picking the,
they're doing work in the fields.
They're,
you know,
they're doing the olives.
They are,
if they're skilled,
right?
If you,
if you get captured and you're like,
Hey,
I can,
you know,
make tables,
then you're going to be put to work
making tables for your owner or if
you're really unlucky you're going to be
sent off to work in one of the mines and
that's again,
that's just going to be producing more
and more wealth for the senatorial
aristocracy.
So that combination of,
of massive amounts of wealth,
massive amounts of slaves,
but always really to the benefit of a
very small elite inside of Rome creates,
I think the,
the fundamentally destabilizing energy
that is going to allow some of these,
of a genuine reformers all the way to
cynical demagogues or all the way,
you know,
ultimately culminating with Julius
Caesar who is the pop laray,
you know,
a reformer slash super ambitious noble
par excellence.
It's all going to culminate with him.
And
the slaves to me is the ultimate
different variable when they do the
comparisons between say the US now in
the Roman republic.
Because even if you wanted to argue
about,
you know,
slave labor being equivalent to low
income labor from over the border or
whatever.
I don't,
I don't see the similarity,
uh,
and it would be if you wanted to make an
analogy with what the Romans did or what
a lot of people's did in,
in earlier history,
it would be like we went into the Middle
East,
toppled Saddam Hussein and brought
thousands of Iraqis back to the United
States to serve us.
Um,
sounds like an inherently unstable
situation to begin with.
I found it interesting when you were
talking about,
um,
who had power in Rome and you talked
about assemblies and that the average
Joe on the street had more,
I would say both more and less power
maybe then one thought,
but you're lying about being able to
control.
Maybe you would.
I think in England they called it king
mob at one point.
The,
the ability to control the political
heart of Rome as,
as the population,
uh,
gave a certain amount of power in the
city.
It always amazed me that,
that in that kind of a situation that
you never had a French revolution kind
of thing when,
when it's so much a large percentage of
the population being balanced out by
such a small class,
but it's that client relationship that
sort of weaves the threads of
connections,
isn't it through the rich,
the poor and the middle classes.
And could you talk a minute about the
equestrian class maybe and a connection
to what today we would call,
you know,
corporations and,
and,
and the fact that because the Roman
senators,
we're not supposed to involve themselves
in business.
It's sort of left a loophole for these
other people to come in and create what
I think today we would call
corporations.
You think that's a fair term?
Yeah,
I think that they were corporations.
Uh,
they were,
they were stock.
You would actually buy stock in these
things.
Okay.
So that's fair.
All right.
Yeah.
And in a,
in a rudimentary way that.
Yeah,
so there was,
there was this prohibition on the
senators,
like somebody who was in the Senate and
you're talking about,
you know,
maybe 300,
350 men and their families are
prohibited from conducting commercial
transactions.
And of course,
just the caveat to this is it,
all of them did it.
They all had,
they all had front,
they all had clients that they would use
were like,
oh,
this is my guy,
you know,
a Publius,
uh,
he just,
he's somebody who just so happens to own
a large amount of commercial real
estate.
And I just happened to know him and it's
like,
it was all a front.
Um,
so most senators were able to dodge this
quite easily,
but the Roman state itself didn't
perform any of their own logistical
enterprises.
Right.
Like even,
right down to right down to tax
collection.
Right.
The Romans did not have state employees
who were tax collectors.
They didn't have state employees who
made uniforms for the legions and ship
them off to the legions.
Um,
this was all done by groups of wealthy
individuals who were not in the Senate,
uh,
because we wanted to be able to get
around that,
you know,
the commercial,
the commercial prohibitions.
So you have these very wealthy families
in Rome who are not a part of the Senate
who are actually the ones who were now
handling the wealth of the society,
the large scale transactions.
They're there.
What they would do is they would come
together,
say that the tax collectors,
if you,
if you want one of these tax farming
contracts and you would say,
okay,
here's how much we're going to bid to
get this contract.
And then the sensor,
once every five years would award,
would award a contract.
And let's say your company won the bid,
then you would now have the right to go
to some province or go to some area and
be in charge of the tax collection where
any amount of money that you,
that you made out collecting taxes above
what you had bid was going to be your
profit.
Um,
that model of extracting taxes from
provincials left itself open to like
wild corruption and abuse,
where if,
if your profit margin is simply however
much you can get out of these people,
um,
it,
it's going to lead you to strong arm
people.
It's going to lead you to demand more
than they actually owed in taxes.
And the Roman government,
the Roman provincial administrations,
I mean the people who would actually be
out there and near Spain or in further
Spain actually representing the Roman
government as,
as like a state agent.
I mean you're talking about less than
100 people.
You're talking about the governor,
his family,
and maybe a couple other elected
officials.
Meanwhile,
the face of Rome,
how they're the people who were actually
running the province is,
is these,
uh,
are these tax farmers with very little
oversight.
And you could kind of like if you were a
tax form or you could go to a family and
say like,
Hey,
you owe me this and taxes.
The provincial pays the tax.
Then you come back around six months
later and say,
Hey,
you want me this tax again?
And the family could say,
hey,
we already paid that tax six months ago
and the tax farmer would just say,
why I don't care.
You pay me a.
and there's no,
there's no oversight to any of this,
uh,
no real effective oversight anyway.
And this creates the same kind of,
um,
really anger and resentment at a look at
what the Roman administrators,
we're up to a,
amongst the provincials out out there in
Spain or in Greece or later,
uh,
in Asia or what is today,
western Turkey.
Um,
that in and of itself lead to a
destabilization of their imperial hold
on things.
And that doesn't all get straightened
out really until augustus comes along
and starts introducing a more stable
reforms.
So fleeced by the contractors,
right?
Very much so.
So let me,
let me ask you,
and this is,
there's a little bit of storytelling
here because I think it's horrifying to
me.
The first time I ever read anything in
ancient history that reminded me of like
George Orwell's 19,
84 a.
and maybe this is just the way my,
my brain connects things.
But when you read about,
you know,
the,
the Marius and the seller arrows,
when,
when prescription lists are going up and
people will read about whether or not
they're being sentenced to die,
I mean,
that has such a third rice kind of
Orwellian may be feel to,
it can go into that a little bit and
talk about,
um,
talk about how different that was for
Rome to wake up and go see if you were
on the list to die.
So
at the beginning of the book,
right,
we're at the,
there's between various political
rivals,
various political groups,
various families,
and they start maneuvering around each
other and they start breaking down these
rules of most of them.
But,
but kind of in the early days,
it's all very ad hoc.
It's all very spontaneous,
uh,
and it's really more about like
maneuvering in new ways that hadn't been
done before.
You start plotting along through the
book.
Yeah,
you get to chapter eight,
you get to chapter nine.
Now we're talking about these groups
having a armed,
like on retainer,
armed gangs who are going to fight for
you.
And by the very end of the book,
it becomes necessary to not just defeat
your rivals and have them say like,
oh,
okay,
well,
I lost that vote,
or I lost that console ship.
I guess I'll go home now.
Um,
you're,
you're operating in a civil war
environment where it's no longer enough
to just beat your rivals.
You have to kill,
you have to kill them.
And if you don't kill them,
then they're going to come back and
they're going to kill you.
So there's,
there's a,
there's a little tight cycle of this
where,
you know,
when.
I don't want to do too much in the way
of spoilers if you haven't read the
book.
But yeah,
I mean,
we,
we kind of all know it all ends badly
for the Romans.
So it's not too much of a spoiler to say
it ends badly for most of these people.
Um,
but the seller goes off to the east,
uh,
to fight his battle,
to fight his war against Mithra Daddy's.
He's had this very intense struggle with
Maurice and Maurice,
his allies and Maurice and his allies
wind up coming into Rome.
And recapturing Rome having been booted
out a couple of weeks earlier and they
start killing the allies of Sela.
This leads when seller comes back a
couple years later for solid to
reciprocate to give as good as it gets.
And starting.
You get literally putting up named
lists,
right?
Here's a list of names.
And if you kill one of these people and
bring me their head,
then I will pay you.
I will pay you money.
And what is kind of.
And it also not just Orwellian,
but also like very Kafka ask,
right?
Where it's all.
It all becomes very arbitrary.
Um,
where the whole,
the whole original point of the
prescription list was so that the people
who sell low was not planning on
killing.
Could rest easy.
Like,
oh,
okay,
well my name's not on the list,
so I'll be fine.
But every day a new list goes up with
new names on it.
And you start having names being added
to the list.
Not because they are enemies of Sela but
because they happen to be enemies of
maybe one of cellos our allies or in the
case of crisis.
And uh,
he is like,
hey,
you own a very rich estate down here in
Campania,
I think I would actually like to own
that estate,
so I think I'm going to declare you an,
an and an enemy of Sela and have you
killed.
So those prescriptions that sort of eat
up the last,
uh,
the last few chapters of the book are
all very bloody and they become,
it takes on an absurd level where it
doesn't even matter whether you're an
enemy of somebody.
And there's a quote from some,
from some rich equestrian who gets
killed in east,
he says,
ah,
done for because of my Alban farm.
And then yeah,
he gets,
he gets killed in his farm,
gets confiscated.
So it moves very quickly from I have to
kill my enemies in order to triumph,
to just like,
let's just kill everybody and confiscate
their stuff.
And it's a wanted dead or alive kind of
approach to getting the enemy's isn't it
sort of like,
uh,
bring us back the head and we'll pay,
I mean,
a little bit different than sending out
your own Gestapo.
Exactly.
And so you actually started having,
it became a fairly lucrative profession
for,
for a couple months and even then for a
couple years where you would go out and
you would be like,
Hey,
well let's,
we'll,
we'll almost like bounty hunters.
Right?
We'll go through.
Just going to say that.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And we'll kill them in and then we'll
get their stuff.
And what is,
you know,
and I also do mention this in the book,
is there does come a point where they
start to realize that,
I mean,
they don't realize the way that we do
that there's,
there are no photographs of anybody,
there are no pictures of anybody.
They don't live in a digital age where
you have a seller can hold up a picture
and then hold up the head and be like,
oh yeah,
you got the right guy.
And you start having them just grab
random dude off the street,
kill them,
chop their head off,
take it in and say,
oh,
this is a.
and then they're like,
kind of scanning the list.
Oh,
this is this guy.
It's guys.
Yeah,
berries.
he's,
yeah,
definitely.
This is his head,
and then you would get your bounty.
Yeah.
It's a little like this black scout that
I'm giving you a black hair.
This is an Apache scalp.
I guarantee it,
you know,
250 gold.
It's all,
it's all very twisted.
it's all very.
It's all quite statistic to be honest.
Something that comes to my mind and I
honestly don't know the answer and the
period we're talking about here,
but,
but discussing the,
the attempts by what we would call
today,
foreign powers are foreign entities to
influence the politics of a vibrant,
let's call it,
on the way to corrupt republic.
Uh,
I just finished a show we did on
Caesar's conquest of Gol and it's
interesting how the more,
um,
shall we call them civilized or more
romanesque.
Golic tribes were basically trying to
influence the politics in Rome during
the period you're talking about.
Are there outside forces from other
states trying to push their agenda or
point of view or the direction they'd
like to see Rome a move towards?
Um,
were,
were any of the outside entities in,
in the geopolitical world of the
Mediterranean at that time trying to
influence Roman politics?
Definitely.
And this had been true for quite some
time where,
you know,
going back even before the beginning of
the book,
after Rome defeats Hannibal in the
second punic war,
there was a,
there was a good like 50 or 60 year
period where Rome was the most powerful
state in the Mediterranean,
but not quite.
I hadn't quite decided they wanted to
annex and rule the Mediterranean
directly where they almost set
themselves up as kind of an arbitrator
of last resort for various city and
kingdoms out there.
So you would have like a couple of Greek
cities who were in having some border
dispute or having some like fishing
rights dispute and they would agree to
take their case to Rome and anytime
these.
So,
so Rome became like a hub of
international embassies and ambassadors
and people constantly envoys coming and
going from really as far away as Syria
and Egypt and all of them are bringing
with them gifts that could only be
described as bribes.
Where you are definitely going to try to
get what you want from the Senate by
making sure that the right senators have
received the right gifts and that that's
something that had really,
this was again,
something that had opened up and,
and does get to a more corrupt version
of the senate than had existed before.
In the context of,
of my book,
the great example of this in my book is
[inaudible] conduct in new media where
he is one of the kings of new media
after,
uh,
after his,
I guess adopted father dies along with
his two brothers,
but [inaudible] would prefer to be the
sole king of new media.
And so he starts breaking treaties.
P starts killing his brothers and he
wants the Senate to just go along with
what he's doing down there rather than
sending in legions or trying to stop
him.
So he absolutely quite brazenly and
quite nakedly is and voice to the Roman
Senate,
laden with gold and laden with gifts and
trying to influence the Senate's
conduct.
And he's quite successful at it.
Uh,
for most of the first seven or eight
years of [inaudible] reign,
he's definitely able to have more or
less paid friends in the Senate,
direct the senate away from the notion
of ever sending the legions in to
confront Jakartha and,
and it,
it gets quite bad where you do have
these senators.
So like,
my God,
this is so brazen,
like where we might actually have to do
something about this,
like you're making us all look bad,
is there,
they're sort of chastising,
uh,
their,
their colleagues in the Senate who are
accepting all of [inaudible] money.
And that point,
um,
the,
the corruption of the Senate by as money
does become a flash point in Roman
politics.
Where,
again,
if you go back to some of these popular
are energies that had been sort of
started this had started fomenting that.
They're saying like,
you know,
Jakartha is brazenly flouting a Roman
authority and Roman law.
We're,
or we're telling him to do things and
he's ignoring us.
He's killing Italians.
He's killing Roman citizens.
And yet we continue to do nothing.
Why is that?
And it's because Jakartha has bribed his
way into the Senate and so they actually
open up,
they're actually able to open up as sort
of like a quasi,
uh,
like a special tribunal that is going to
start to investigate and prosecute those
in the Senate who were guilty of being
corrupted by Jakartha,
which gets me to a question of tipping
points and points of no return when you
look at the,
you know,
when,
when people like to look for examples
from the past to try to analyze our own
times and you do quite a bit of that in
the book and I love it.
But when you look at our situation now
and the people who founded this country
and who wrote the documents,
uh,
that form our framework,
we're keen students of the Roman
republic obviously.
And so they were paying attention to the
flaws in their system and how things
went wrong and try to make,
uh,
make changes in their own version
obviously,
so that we wouldn't fall down the same
rat hole.
But when do you think it was
irreversible?
In other words,
when do you think the death spiral had
been reached?
Where you can imagine now,
uh,
were,
were the,
the,
the points of entry and the,
the ability to compromise it,
just gone to farming.
Is it when the violence first breaks out
or is it after that or is it before
that,
where do you,
if you had to find a tipping point when
the iceberg struck the titanic,
maybe it's a better way to put it.
Where is it in your mind?
Well,
so I'll answer that in a sec.
I will say that,
um,
you know,
one of the reasons we know so much about
everything I just said about Jakartha is
because the Roman historian Salus
elected to write about the jigger war
and Bertha's corruption of the Senate
and the battles that ensued a.
and Saul was to somebody who was
writing.
He was,
he was a partisan of Julius Caesar's.
Uh,
so he's writing his books right around
the forties and thirties BC.
So he,
he knows how it all turns out and he's
writing,
you know,
fairly,
fairly contemporaneously with events.
And he wrote about the [inaudible] war
specifically because he said that was
the tipping point,
right?
That was when he said that was the first
moment that laying on like the old,
uh,
the corruption of the Senate was first
challenged.
And what led to what became these
partisan battles that ultimately
destroyed the senate.
He,
he actually identified the jigger thien
war as,
as,
as that tipping point,
which is why he wrote about it.
Now,
could the senate had,
or could,
could,
could the Roman republic have pulled out
of it at that point?
Like,
I think so the point that I come to is,
it's,
it's really,
it's solace conduct,
uh,
at the very end,
what,
what becomes the end of the book,
but solids conduct,
um,
during some of his final showdown is
really what sets the final permanent
blueprint for how you can achieve power
by completely disregarding just anything
but brute force.
So Sala is going to,
he,
he loses a political confrontation.
So Louisa,
he,
he had command of this eastern army.
He Marius uses the power of the assembly
to strip sela of his command and send
Sela away what Martez thinks he's sent,
so a packing for good and sell really is
faced with this choice of,
do I accept this defeat?
Do I get stripped of my command?
Do I accept the humiliation that I have
just endured at the hands of my rival
Maurice?
Or do I go back to my five legions who
are loyal to me personally and do I
point them at Rome and March on Rome to
a victorious from Rome and reclaim what
I think is rightfully mine.
Once one solid did that and then
ultimately he emerges victorious from
everything.
That is the point that men like Julius
Caesar and men like pompey a WHO's an
early partisan of sellers are going to
be looking at later on down the road and
saying,
well,
if,
if nothing else,
I can do that.
I mean,
this is.
We don't have any,
I don't think like exact quotes or proof
in,
in the,
in the historical record that Julius
Caesar was,
was actively thinking about seller when
he crossed the Rubicon.
But it had to have been on his mind and
the proof was in the pudding for solace
conduct.
If you get a large army,
keep them loyal to you,
you can use them to prosecute your own
domestic political enemies and emerge
victorious and become a dictator for
life.
So I,
I sort of put it there.
I think that Cellos,
cellos decisions in those,
in those moments,
in the early days of the civil wars is
really what,
what made it so that the republic,
there was no,
I don't feel like there was any coming
back from that.
You had mentioned when Kayas,
Caracas was,
was looking at his broad range of
reforms you had talked about,
had they,
I'm going from memory here,
but you'd said if they had been enacted,
it would have foreseen a lot of the
changes that Augustus era Roman reforms
had implemented and obviously a long
time ahead of time if something like
that had gone forward.
Is that the example of a reform moment
that had to come to pass,
uh,
the inevitable death spiral that
happened might have been avoided?
I think so.
And it's because they're,
there would not have been quite the
energy or the impetus to,
um,
to just crack the state in half,
right.
It,
you get to a point where if you're
governing apparatus or whatever it
happens to be,
if enough people start to feel like that
governing apparatus is not working for
them,
it's not doing anything.
For me personally,
why do I owe it as an institution,
any kind of loyalty,
my loyalty ought to go to the thing or
to the people or in the Roman case,
oftentimes to the general who's going to
be guaranteeing me the kind of security
that I want in life,
which is I want a plot of land.
I want decent wages.
I want a,
I want someplace to be able to settle
in,
retire when I'm done here.
By the time you get to the later
republic that is providable by,
by warlords,
uh,
which is,
you know,
you could absolutely describe Caesar as
a warlord,
um,
once,
once it starts to become those guys who
are delivering on the promises that,
that are being made rather than the
state itself.
Yeah.
There's,
what is it that they had to be loyal to
the Senate and people of Rome abstractly
for,
um,
so when you,
when you get to these moments when you
can make some of these,
when you can have a little bit of
foresight and say to yourself,
or is this model working for,
for the entire citizen population?
Or is it just working for a tiny elite,
you know,
once you start ignoring the rest of the
citizens and say,
ah,
it's working for a tiny elite,
but that's fine.
They'll just accept it.
You do create a breach of legitimacy and
you do a alienate people to the point
where they're not.
No,
they're no longer loyal to the system at
all.
And that's how you get people just
crashing it over.
And,
and most people practically not even
caring.
And you.
Yeah.
The private military thing which used to
be illegal in Rome.
Why did the Romans,
why,
why did the,
the citizenry or the Senate put up with
the change that.
I mean,
if you wanted to put the major thing
that the founding fathers of the United
States,
of course tried to do was to make sure
that the citizen,
uh,
leadership controlled the military so
that we had that separation,
but,
but they kind of had that separation in
Rome once upon a time.
What made,
and we'll make this the last question,
but what made the,
the,
the circumstances or,
or public opinion or senatorial opinion?
Um,
I was going to say change,
but the word might be put up.
Why did they put up with it?
The raising of private armies?
Yeah.
The reason why they put up with it
initially was because Rome was facing an
emergency military situation,
um,
where they were sort of simultaneously
around the age of,
around Maria because Maria is sort of
the great,
you know,
it,
it had been moving in this direction of
um,
just a backup in case people don't know
this,
uh,
previously to serve in the legions.
You had to own a certain amount of
property.
You actually had to literally be rich
enough to serve in the legions.
And by the middle of of the book,
by in the middle of the storm,
before the storm,
you get Marius making this fateful
request for an exemption from that
requirement and just let me enroll any
warm body who wants to show up and I'll
train them and I'll teach them how to be
soldiers.
That was.
That was a fairly momentous change in in
how the Romans conducted politics and
war and does have a lot to do with that.
Those people who are now going to be
loyal more to their general than to the
state because it's the general who's
going to be providing them and
guaranteeing them a the riches and land
that they hope to get out of their
service.
So the reason why I think in that moment
why the Senate says,
okay,
yeah you can,
you can draft anybody is that they had.
They had an ongoing war in north Africa.
There was a huge slave rebellion that
had consumed a,
that had consumed Sicily.
And then the kimbery this,
this great Germanic hoard that it
would've just been sort of wandering
around Europe for like 15 years,
would constantly come back around and
the north.
So the northern border was very
insecure.
So I think it was,
it was,
it was a matter of just like,
like in this emergency situation,
we need to raise men and we need to
raise a lot of men.
So yeah,
just go ahead and do it.
And I think from that point on they just
sort of realized that,
um,
uh,
this was,
this was a way to keep up with the
manpower needs that their empire now
have.
They were no longer just this little
city state that was occasionally
skirmishing with the Sam nights down
around capital a.
This is,
you know,
we have,
we have garrison's we need to be filling
in Spain and North Africa and up and
Gaul.
And as a,
as they move into goal of the Macedonian
frontier over in Greece,
they're now,
they're now in charge of western Turkey.
Um,
how,
how are we going to keep the legions
filled?
I think once,
I think once they made the decision to
go over to like,
let's just drop this property
requirement in general,
I think it was fairly wildly successful
in terms of their ability to raise the
men needed to run their empire and then
you know,
how does,
how does that move over to the real
danger point,
which is people raising personal armies
and I think a lot of this like a decent
enough analogy like not exactly is like
a political party going and looking for
a candidate who can sell finance their
campaign,
political parties at the state level,
at the national level.
Always love a candidate who can walk in
and say,
oh,
by the way,
like the party doesn't need to give me
any money.
I'll just do.
I'll just do this all out of my own
pocket.
Because I'm,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a hedge fund manager.
I am a,
an owner of a business or like Michael
Bloomberg is just like whatever it is
that he's sitting on top of.
Right?
Like he,
like the Democratic Party didn't need to
give him any money.
He could just do it all himself and the
same was really true of,
uh,
of later if people like pompey,
who could say,
Hey,
I'm going to go,
I can go raise my own army.
Like you don't even,
you don't even have to worry about it.
Like you elect me console,
I'll do all the work for Ya.
Um,
that's a,
that's a very,
that's a very immediately attractive
proposition for most people,
especially out there.
Maybe you don't want to go to war,
but you have a candidate who was like,
don't worry,
I'll get my guys myself and you don't
have to do it if you don't want to.
Um,
that's where you start getting these
personal legions being raised and once
those personal legions are being raised
again,
now we're just,
you know,
the late republic is just a clash of
warlords and that is really right now
when you look at it and you say,
okay,
I see some similarities,
but there some real big differences and
we haven't gotten there yet.
Right?
Sure.
And I,
I mean honestly like the military thing,
you know,
the United States has gone through a bit
of a similar process after Vietnam where
we said we're no longer going to do
this,
like temporary conscription into an army
to go off and fight and instead we're
going to make it all volunteer and um,
and all professional,
right?
I mean,
that's a similarity.
But there's so much about the
institutional,
what the US Army,
the US Navy institutionally is,
um,
does not resemble the personal warlord
legions of the late republic.
Right?
Like the paymaster is not your kernel.
The paymaster is,
is really,
it's the United States of America.
And we can,
you know,
our checks don't ever bounce when they
go out there to some private or sergeant
or some major.
So you don't have them being loyal
specifically to just one,
just one commander out there.
And then I have also heard,
you know,
I've,
I've had the good fortune to be friends
with a lots of veterans guys who were in
the military now or who have left and
are now veterans just back out in the
civilian world with the rest of us that,
I mean,
there's enough that goes on with trooper
rotations,
right,
where you're kind of bouncing between
units.
You're,
you're never forming one of these like
20 year long bonds where you guys have
all been serving together forever.
Um,
so I don't,
I,
I don't fear right now like the role of
the US army,
uh,
in some kind of a,
in some kind of war,
Lord style clash.
I don't see it happening anytime soon.
One of the great firewalls that's
actually working still.
Right.
I hope so.
Listen,
is there anything,
Mike,
that I didn't ask you about that you
want to make sure we know about the book
or some of the story?
Uh,
I specifically focused on the things
that I was interested in,
but there's a heck of a lot in this
piece.
What else should the listeners know?
Well,
I think,
I think the one thing that we didn't
touch on that is a,
that is a pretty major part of the book
that has similarities to the United
States is this issue of the non.
The Non Roman Italians were.
Sure,
sure.
Yeah.
Were just in case you don't know the
backstory of this here,
I'll do it real quick,
is that when Rome conquered Italy during
the Sam night wars,
which is a couple of hundred years
before my book comes along.
Um,
the Romans did not annex these people
directly into the Roman state.
They instead signed these,
uh,
these treaties with the city,
so a city in an area or a city and
Umbria would then become merely an ally
of realm.
And when,
whenever the Romans came around to ask
for a legionaries for the army's,
the city had to provide them.
But other than that they were mostly
left to their own devices.
They could govern themselves.
They weren't really taxed that heavily.
But what happens is when you get to the
period of my book,
a couple hundred years later,
these guys had been inside of Roman
civilization in every meaningful way for
hundreds of years.
And yet they were still,
you couldn't even call them second class
citizens.
They were not citizens at all.
Uh,
and they're facing the same problems,
the same economic problems that they're
roman cousins are,
except they don't even have the right to
vote in an assembly.
They don't even have the right to send
candidates for office and be like,
well,
Hey,
what about us?
So they were on top of everything else.
They,
they were facing economic,
economic problems and also didn't have
any kind of political voice at all.
And so that combined with the sort of,
the general problems that are created by
the skyrocketing economic inequality,
that leads to a [inaudible] style,
confrontational style of politics that
now defines,
that now defines the Republican,
that entire force of it,
again,
like energy,
I guess you could call it.
Um,
the Italian question is what's
ultimately triggers the great civil wars
of Maurice and Sala is the Italians
constantly demanding citizenship.
The Romans constantly saying,
we're not going to give you citizenship,
and what it finally takes is a massive
bloody and destructive civil war where
the Italians are not trying to break
away from Roman rule.
They're trying to force their way into
Roman road.
It was a.
it's going to be a war on behalf of
political equality rather than a war
premised on political independence.
So that's,
that's like the other big thing that's
floating around out there,
but other than that,
you just.
You just read the book and I'll explain
it all to you.
As one of my professors said,
every educated person in the Western
world should know the story that Mike
Duncan catalogs in the storm before the
storm,
the beginning of the end of the Roman
republic.
Mike,
thank you for coming on the program.
I wish you the greatest success.
Thank you very much.
Like I said,
I think that this is the.
I think you could not have chosen a
better subject and I agree with you.
It's shocking that this doesn't already
have 20 books on the bookshelf about
this.
Considering how awesome and like you,
I mean,
you know,
it's hard to initiate enough disclaimers
where you tell people,
okay,
there's so many different things.
It's not really like us,
but look at all these things that are
like us,
you know?
Yeah.
I figured if,
if,
if you're going to do it because like
one of the things that I always push
against is that I don't think that we're
anywhere near like the fall of Rome,
which is,
which is something that you hear from
people like,
oh,
the Syrian refugees are just like the
vandals.
No,
not really.
No.
Wait,
can we start killing each other over
political things then we're starting to
move a little bit in the are.
I mean,
yeah,
like if,
if we actually have like a mass
migrating population that has like an
entire,
uh,
entire armed force that can go toe to
toe with the US army,
then I guess,
yeah,
we can start talking about it,
but I don't think we're anywhere near
that.
I think your $300 senators with Tiberius
Grok as.
I think that's the moment where the,
the sea change would happen.
Yeah,
I think,
I think that that period of the Grok
eyes is enough that I'm,
I'm happy to now insert this idea into
people's heads and saying like,
this is the period we need to be paying
attention.
Important.
Exactly.
It's not just for interesting.
It's like that's what my professor was
pointing out that if you're an American
in this system,
this is a story that our founding
fathers thought was worth knowing
probably for an informed citizenry of a,
of a modern commercial.
Imperial Republic might be a good idea
to buy Mike Duncan's book.
So that's the way I'm going to phrase
it.
Uh,
if dude,
if I can do anything
for you,
I'm here.
Okay,
great.
I really appreciate it.
That was fun.
My thanks to Mike Duncan.
It was great to finally digitally
interact with him.
Go out and pick up the storm before the
storm.
We will link to it on our website.
If you pick it up through Amazon,
why don't you do so through our search
window at Dan Carlin Dot com and that
will help us out too.
Sure.
The older hardcore history shows can be
a bit traumatic with titles like death
throes of the republic judgment at
Nineveh and addicted to bondage.
We just consider that to be truth in
advertising.
No pain,
no gain is Armato.
Pick up the entire catalog from Dan
Carlin.com.